when I was a boy heaven was here and  America was here you can be anything you  could do anything  I am the wrong person to have discovered  this if you don't speak for them  I found a disease that no one has ever  seen repetitive head trauma chokes the  ring the NFL does not want to talk to  you you turn on the lights and gave  their biggest bogeyman a name you're  going to war with a corporation that  owns a day of the week no proof was  presented today because there simply  isn't any they have to listen to us this  is bigger than they are  what do you think they're doing to you  now that's nothing you have no idea how  bad that's good yeah they have to keep  going you want you to say you made it  all up  they continue to deny my work men  continue to die  sometimes in life you're asked to leave  it alone but sometimes you can  who are you tell the truth tell the  truth